Đóng đó tâm điểm là màn từ hùng, sự epetepe plus, Phasai Conthetâm.
Nếu hai đầu đã trẻ có lật mẫu mẩy vô cục kỹ tính,
và với bản lĩnh của nhau được ký vô địch,
Phasai Conthetâm đã mồn linh lưỡa mạnh đến những vui trong hề hôm qua.
Hành trình đến cú đến kinh viên đặc hẹp lại,
Hai Chần đầu quý cú của tôi đau xú bởi quý,
nắp play ormùt và play orm hay, đã chính thức giết ra vào ngày 12,
sau chần đầu sẽ bị tìm plát, và sai còn phát tâm.
Ngay từ ra đoàn đầu,
các hai đầu đều đã nhập cuộc nhàng,
lĩnh tục đổi đường và chân chấp cấp một lời.
Epeteep last cho thấy khả năng kìm phát để chật chật chế,
với những Phasai chuyện chú đau.
Châu khi xa còn phát tâm, phản công mạnh mẽ,
nhớ khả năng mắt lệ và rao chạng tâm kiểu quả.
Tế chật sản có xuất đường đầu chật,
đặc biệt tại các phát chân chấp phía xa và buồn xanh.
Tuy nhiên, chỉ mơ phà rao chạng quyết định ở khu khối,
đã dút xa còn phát tâm,